[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW EDWARDS: I'm studying how extremely
intense lasers interact with plasmas.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW EDWARDS: I've been interested in how
lasers interact with matter for a long time.
And I got interested in this subject because
it's an extremely-- it's a new and exciting
area of physics.
So we shine a laser on a piece of glass.
And in this interaction, the electrons are
driven close to the speed of light, and this
is the process that produces the radiation
we're interested in.
This is a two-dimensional simulation.
The laser comes in and it's focused, and you
can see that it starts to distort this plasma
surface.
And the blue dots represent electrons.
So we're driving the electrons, creating kind
of a cool pattern of oscillations.
As it's reflecting from the surface, we produce
this high frequency x-ray light.
We're accelerating some electrons out of the
target.
So this is showing that we've created a source
of coherent radiation, as well as accelerated
fast electrons.
Professor Mikhailova started here around the
same time I started as a graduate student.
And it was suggested that I go talk to her
because it seemed like she would be doing
work that I might be interested in.
JULIA MIKHAILOVA: The subject of our research
is extreme states of matter.
It's a very interesting and fascinating subject.
MATTHEW EDWARDS: She's a very accomplished
scientist, so I was really excited to have
the opportunity to get to work with her.
JULIA MIKHAILOVA: I could choose many words,
like I could he's very innovative, he's brilliant,
he is very kind, many words.
MATTHEW EDWARDS: I do a combination of computational
and experimental work.
And so for me, I mean, both of those things
are the things that I enjoy doing.
When you do an experiment, when you run a
simulation, and that moment before you look
at the results and you don't know quite how
it's going to turn out, you're going to see
something that nobody has really looked at
before.
And nobody knows the answer to.
And so it's a chance to see something new
and hopefully, find out something new about
how the world works.
[MUSIC PLAYING]